[Music]
president biden gave his first major
foreign policy speech today claiming
america is back i didn't even know we
went anywhere
former secretary of state mike pompeo is
here to respond next but first the chief
breaking news correspondent trace
gallagher
who has the key takeaways from the
speech
congressman good to see you on both
china and russia president biden played
a bit of good cop
bad cop on china the president said he
is willing to work with beijing
when it's in america's interest of
course not to be confused with
america first biden also said he would
confront china's economic abuses human
rights violations
and attacks on intellectual property he
did not offer details
on russia mr biden revealed an agreement
to extend a nuclear arms treaty
but also offered this warning watch
i made it clear to president putin in a
manner very different from my
predecessor
that the days of the united states
rolling over
in the face of russia's aggressive
actions interfering with our elections
cyber attacks poisoning its citizens are
over the president also directed defense
secretary lloyd austin to review the
global footprint of u.s forces to make
sure it's appropriate for national
security
biden also stopped the withdrawal of
more than 9 000 u.s troops from germany
former president trump offered he needs
to pay more for its own defense
meantime president biden announced an
end to american support for offensive
operations in yemen
where saudi-led forces are fighting the
iranian-backed houthi rebels
biden did say america will continue to
help saudi arabia defend its sovereignty
and the president plans to increase the
number of refugees
admitted into the u.s watch
this executive order will position us to
be able to raise the refugee admissions
back up to 125 000 persons
for the first full fiscal year of the
biden harris administration
the trump administration set the refugee
cap at 15
000. trey
thank you trace joining me now with his
first reaction to all of this
former secretary of state former head of
the cia
former congressman from the great state
of kansas mike pompeo mr secretary how
are you
trey i'm great it's great to be with you
tonight thanks for having me on the show
it's good to see you
it's good to see you too mike all right
president biden says america's back i
didn't know we went anywhere what's your
reaction to that
oh goodness gracious trey uh back does
he mean back to when isis controlled a
caliphate in syria that was the size of
britain
i hope not president trump and our team
took that down
when he says back when america is back
does he mean backblood and china walk
all over us
destroying millions of jobs in places
like kansas and south carolina that we
know so well trey
i hope that's not what he means by back
but does he mean
he talked about allies when he said go
back does he mean
back to dissing allies and friends like
israel and treating the terrorists in
iran
like friends by giving them 150 billion
dollars in pallets of cash
i i don't think the american people can
afford to go back
to eight more years of barack obama's
foreign policy i hope they'll move
forward with a
foreign policy look much more like our
america first foreign policy
mike i want to ask you about three
countries in particular let's start with
china
we know what china has done to this
country via the pandemic
you are acutely aware of what china
is doing and has done to its own
citizens
what do you have to say about that
well china is behaving in a way that we
haven't seen
any nation behave since the 1930s tray
you know we have
all over the world and in washington d.c
and in los angeles we have museums
that talk about the horrors that took
place in the 1932 and we we talk about
never again and yet on our watch on our
time we're watching the chinese
communist party engage in exactly those
same kinds of behaviors
with respect to the uyghurs and other
minorities there the world has a
responsibility
to take this on i determined that this
was in fact a genocide
that was taking place and i hope i hope
this administration will take it just as
seriously
as president trump and our team did
he mention russia and election
interference
um i i think you're look i had the
pleasure
working with you in the house you're as
tough on russia as anybody i know
what is this notion that all of a sudden
we're going to get tough on russia
well if you if you'll remember trey the
interference that i think he's referring
to
took place when he was the vice
president united states
this was the election of 2016. long
before the trump administration came
into
power instead in 2018 and then again in
the election in 2020 we
worked hard to prevent russia from
interfering in our election i'm proud of
the work that we did
i'm proud of the work we did to push
back against russia remember they took
crimea during the obama administration
i mean we don't want to go back he talks
about america being back i don't think
our friends and allies want that i know
that the american people don't want it
you know mike the president said that
the diplomats job is to rebuild trust
around the world
this is what has me vexed a few months
ago we were
killing an iranian general and now he
wants to sit at the bargaining table
with the iranians about nuclear
uh weaponry uh how do you go from
killing generals to saying okay we trust
you enough even though you still want to
push israel
uh into the water
well that particular general was
plotting
to kill americans and we weren't going
to let happen president trump wasn't
going to let it happen the
the world said you can't do it it'll
create world war iii it didn't
in fact what it did is it demonstrated
the capacity for america to execute
deterrence against iran so going back to
try and cut that deal from 2015 would be
a calamity
a calamity for the gulf states a
calamity for our friend and partner
in the jewish homeland of israel and the
calamity for the people the united
states of america presents real risk
that the world's largest state sponsor
of terror will once again have the
resources the power the capacity
to do real harm
the president today also said our
relations with some of our allies have
been neglected
and abused uh what is your reaction to
his perception of our relationship with
our allies
you know trey when i was a secretary of
state i shot straight i i told him like
i was that probably won't
frankly surprise you uh and there were
some cold receptions in brussels and
some of the salons of europe
there's no doubt about that i i'm proud
of the work we did we
we we spoke the truth we didn't do work
as if
we and we knew the world as we wished it
to be
what we did was deliver good outcomes so
ask prime minister modi ask
prime minister abe ask ask prime
minister morrison in australia
all of these leaders understood that
america had their back we were their
friends we were their partners
we were working diligently to deliver
security we did that
they were great friends great allies
great partners and i am proud of the
alliances that this administration built
you know mike we met while we were
investigating the deaths of four brave
americans
um in libya uh and you were an
indispensable part of finding out what
happened to them and i know how
seriously you take the security
of those women and men who work on our
behalf
i don't think anyone was lost on your
watch
tell me about the security profile when
you were secretary of state
well trey you and i did serve on the
benghazi committee together you were a
great leader
we were aimed singularly and making sure
we understood why it was we lost an
ambassador and why three other
great americans were killed in that
tragic incident
every day i woke up whether i was the
cia director then at the state
department
saying how do i make sure we we've got
to take risks we've got to have people
in far-off places how do i make sure we
are moving
heaven and earth to make sure that those
people are protected and
through that hard work and the grace of
god i didn't have any of my
officers either the cia or the state
department killed during my time in
leadership
we learned a lot trey we have a
responsibility to these great americans
working overseas and working in
difficult places
to make sure they are safe and secure as
america can possibly deliver
and the trump administration did just
that
last question you spent a lot of time in
government sir
trey it's hard to know i i did i served
as a soldier a long time ago now i
then had the incredible opportunity to
serve alongside you as a member of
congress and then these two
jobs in the trump administration we'll
have to see what life brings for now i'm
going to take a little break
work hard think a little bit right a
little bit and then we'll see what's in
front of us
well thank you mr secretary for your
work from west point
all the way into your last day as
secretary of state my best to your
family and susan too
thank you thank you right right back at
you trey thank you so long